all right guys
bang bang super excited to have alex
here thanks so much for doing this man
thanks for having me pam absolutely so
you build uh one of the most fascinating
companies uh
in crypto you're a bitcoin only business
we'll get to that in a second
before we kind of jump into river
financial talk to us a little bit about
your background
kind of what you did before you started
the company
so i got into bitcoin because of an
interest i had as an undergraduate
university i studied aerospace
engineering at university of maryland
but was really interested in economics
eventually i read a paper called the
denationalization of money by friedrich
hayek
and got really obsessed with this idea
of building a financial institution that
offered
private money i thought i would make my
own money someday
backed by commodities or something like
that but then i started going down that
rabbit hole and realized that there's a
lot of
challenges trying to do it yourself uh i
saw what happened to liberty dollar
liberty reserve it didn't end too well
for them
so when i discovered bitcoin i was like
holy cow
you know this fulfills the prophecy it's
neither private nor
government controlled it's this new
system
new paradigm we've never seen before but
it's fascinating and i became instantly
obsessed
and so i moved to silicon valley at the
end of 2013 and
been out there pretty much ever since
working mostly in the bitcoin space
and then started river about a year and
a half
ago um before that was working
i went to actually i went to grad school
out there i helped ta the first bitcoin
class at stanford
i uh also worked at a uh investment fund
called polychain capital helping them
lead some of their
bitcoin investments and also helping
them build some of the technical
infrastructure
to help them manage manage their assets
and so yeah i've had quite a fun time
out there
absolutely and so when you left uh ply
chain you decided to go and build river
what was the general impetus uh for for
wanting to start a company and kind of
what was that initial idea say hey this
is what i'm gonna go build
so the initial impetus was kind of the
itch i had back
as an undergrad to build this financial
institution i had seen a lot
of people in the space build exchanges
and
focus on offering access to multitudes
of cryptocurrencies
um you know the big long tail coinbase
had started with bitcoin and then
and then expanded very quickly you know
to supporting as many coins as possible
and i had never seen anyone go down the
route of actually focusing only on
bitcoin and building
more of a bank looking institution
around it and going deep on bitcoin and
brought across financial services i felt
like the exchange business was really
cool but it
it's really i see it as a local maximum
and the global maximum is building
a bitcoin financial institution and so i
you know all these other companies went
right and no one went left and i
you know i saw that as a big opportunity
and that's the whole
hypothesis behind river got it and so
what did you build first and kind of um
also talk a little bit about like why
bitcoin only
yeah so uh so right now we're a bitcoin
brokerage and
uh custodian in 31 states so we focus on
the higher end of the market
the mass affluent to the ultra high net
worth individuals and we make it really
really easy for people to buy bitcoin
and securely custody that bitcoin over
the next year we'll be expanding across
financial services
um providing providing things like um
well we already provide access to uh
self-custody services
and then other things like tax
advantaged accounts lending
and other financial services that banks
offer so you know starting
starting the company in 2019
uh was a very interesting experience and
then the transition between the 2019 era
to the 2020 era uh into the covet era
has been very fascinating
and um it's been pretty crazy ride
yeah talk a little bit about maybe uh
other companies in the space they've
gone on to add other assets than just
bitcoin
um you guys have kind of held steady on
bitcoin only
um how do you look at those other
businesses do you think that those are
kind of hey that's for each company to
kind of make their own decision do you
think
that's a bad strategy just talk through
that a little bit
so the way we view this is that being
bitcoin only is economically in our
interest
and allows us to move much faster than
the competition because we focus on
bitcoin only we can provide unique
features that our competitors can't for
example we offer access to the lightning
network
we have this cool feature where you can
um connect a hardware wallet and see all
your bitcoin that you self-custody and
then when you buy bitcoin and river you
can easily transfer it to your harbor
wallet
and see all the tax plot information
transferred as well
all these little things that we do would
be orders of magnitude more complicated
to do if we supported multiple
cryptocurrencies
just adding one more cryptocurrency to a
product like ours
four to ten xs the complexity of the
systems on the back end that we have
and so we see it as a massive
competitive advantage
we see this long tail of assets that
these other companies are focused on
kind of just providing trading services
for as
kind of interesting things to you know
bet on or gamble on but really
um we don't see it as money we see
bitcoin as money
and so if bitcoin is the next money of
the world somebody needs to build the
next
banking services around bitcoin and
that's
why we're focused on bitcoin because we
don't see any other asset that
sits at that level additionally as a
business
our goal is do one thing and do it well
right and
why spread ourselves thin across 100
different cryptocurrencies when
the vast majority of people only really
want bitcoin and that's what we rarely
get asked
by our customers even to support other
cryptocurrencies so that wouldn't really
make sense for us
absolutely one of the things that you've
been able to kind of build out is this
white glove service right it really
makes people feel special it really kind
of
seems like hey river cares talk a little
bit about that process
and kind of how that came to fruition
and and how you guys executed because
i've seen people posting the photos
online and
it just looks you know really cool it's
kind of a short way to say it
so one of the biggest shortcomings we
saw
from existing cryptocurrency companies
before starting river was the client
services and the client experience
i knew of people with lots of money
on coinbase who couldn't even get
anybody on the phone
can you imagine you know wiring millions
of dollars to a financial institution
before ever talking to somebody that
works there
uh and yet that's what a lot of these
silicon valley kind of startups expect
people to do
um so we saw that and saw that one of
the biggest barriers
preventing people from buying bitcoin
was the fact that there wasn't a company
out there that just had really good
service
uh because it bitcoin is very
intimidating and
from a business perspective the way we
view our client services is
if we can make bitcoin much less
intimidating for people
we can grow our business really well and
and so that's really the goal with our
client services is to take away the
intimidation from bitcoin
make people feel uh appreciated
and uh and that we don't take their
business for granted and um and earn
their business got it and so
talk through kind of who's buying now
and how is it going so far you've been
at it for 18
months and any metrics you can share or
kind of any updates in terms of how it's
actually going
so we we see the full spectrum of
clients
at river however uh most of our volume
in fact probably i'd say 70
or so of our volume comes from people
over the age of
50. uh a lot of people
a lot of older people are buying bitcoin
right now and significant sums
in absolute terms significant sums they
typically start with a small percentage
of their own assets
but if you look at the wealth in the
united states and the wealth in the
world you know most of it is held by
older people
which is kind of natural because older
people have had longer to accumulate
wealth
so it as is
covid and the the subsequent
social instability and economic
uncertainty that has
uh come from that has really been
a big catalyst for a lot of these older
people deciding to finally buy bitcoin
and it's for a number of different
reasons um some of them
their own family has been through wealth
confiscation you know in in other
parts of the world and they viscerally
understand how important it is to
have assets that they can completely
control and
you know get out quickly is something
where it really goes south
fast um other people who have
significant amounts of assets kind of
they ask themselves well let's see you
know 99 percent of my wealth is tied to
assets that
you know our real estate equities things
that are very locked down to
the the united states and if something
did happen in the united states god
forbid
you know what could i get out so that me
and my family would have something
and and you know there's gold in bitcoin
and gold has its own set of challenges
like good luck getting a lot of that out
so um and then third is the third
category is really people who just see
it as an uncorrelated asset
in a world where it's unclear where your
money should be i mean stocks are
all-time
highs but it's unclear why because the
markets i mean
there's look at all the unemployment and
the economic you know
uncertainty that we face that's not
really justified
they're printing trillions of dollars
every year now um
so where do they where do i put my money
i mean there's only ever going to be 21
million bitcoin that's pretty simple
and so you know we see a lot of
different
you know pads people take towards
bitcoin but all of them kind of
are around this idea of like increasing
instability
got it and when the people come in it
sounds like they're making kind of a
small purchase and they kind of crank up
um in terms of larger and larger
purchases any idea from the clients that
you guys have
where they're getting to from a uh
portfolio percentage standpoint are we
talking about getting to one percent
allocations five percent
are people at the age of 50 going to 25
percent like like any ideas there where
they're actually getting
i think they're typically starting
around one percent and then going
anywhere between five to ten percent uh
is what we've seen largely
um there are there are the unique people
who do go further
the ones who are really in to bitcoin
but
we're also in the very early innings
here so
it and and all of our clients are are on
us
on a journey and they're all on
different steps of their journey so
that's what we've seen so far
but who knows where that will go longer
term
so um but but so far we don't see most
older people
going all in
what do you think it will take to change
uh that right like what will it take to
get
the older people to go all in well i
don't think
i think most of them i i doubt most of
them will ever be 100 in bitcoin i mean
they own properties and businesses
those are big parts of their net worth
and those aren't things that they would
necessarily replace with bitcoin um
i think really the the bigger question
is uh
you know how how will
more more older people or more people in
general get exposed initially exposed to
bitcoin
and and why aren't people buying bitcoin
today who
you know who otherwise might um if you
look at the numbers
um you know about especially in the
older demographic
um only about 10 of the people who are
interested in buying bitcoin actually
have it
and so an interesting question is like
why haven't they bought it and i think
it's really it's just very intimidating
younger people have internet communities
to that they have access to
to ask questions and socialize if you
think about the average older person you
know they're not on twitter every day
they're not on reddit every day
so they have this curiosity in bitcoin
but none of their friends know anything
about it
no one they know knows anything about it
so they're kind of just on their own
island
and i think um the question is how do
you reach them on that island
and uh that's true what we try and do
and i think that's
also there's a big opportunity for you
know content creators like yourself to
to reach these folks because we've
noticed a lot of them when they find a
podcast they also really love
listening to podcasts yeah it makes a
lot of sense
and i guess as you guys kind of see
these people
um trickle in it feels like there's an
entire demographic of people who they
know they should own bitcoin
like they've already decided yes this
would be a good idea but
the action of going to buy it it's
almost like they've mentally convinced
themselves oh that's the decision i
should make
uh but they don't execute do you see
kind of the service-based approach you
guys have taken does that break down
that barrier does that make it easier
for people um
or do they kind of look at it as hey
this is no different than an exchange i
just happen to have a phone number
attached that i can call
this cert the human element 100 breaks
down the barrier
uh at the end of the day everyone i
think really appreciates
human engagement with the business
especially when it's positive
a positive experience and we just
we see our goal as educating our
prospective clients whether or not they
decide to buy bitcoin or not we don't
give them five we don't get financial
advice
we don't tell people you should buy
bitcoin our our job is to
educate people about bitcoin and make it
easy as possible for them to do so if
they wanted to buy it
and um so i think 100 though uh the
human
element that we add to the experience is
is the game changer
got it you guys also have a self-custody
product for what i understand talk a
little bit about what you guys are doing
on the custody side
so one of the things that is big in the
bitcoin ethos is
having the ability to fully control your
own wealth
and our our motto here at river is we
want to be the company that you can
trust
but you don't have to trust so our goal
is to make it as easy as possible for
our clients to self-custody their own
bitcoin if they ever wanted to
and and removing the barriers to
self-custody that are there
right now it's very challenging to do so
so one of the
products we built out was a deep harbor
wallet integration with river
so when you set up your river account
and you buy bitcoin
uh you can actually connect a hardware
wallet
and uh pull in all of the information
from that hardware wallet into your
river account so you can see all of the
coins that you custody yourself
and all the coins that river custody is
on your behalf
and so then when you buy bitcoin and
river you can actually
transfer over the bitcoin to your
hardware wallet with a click of a button
because we've actually we have the
ability to generate new addresses for
you
to do all your historical transactions
and then and self-custody those coins
yourself without losing any visibility
into the tax data um and the balance
so if you have a ledger and you have
your river at bitcoin uh
you have your bitcoin at river you can
see all the bitcoin at once when you log
into river whether
you control it or we do i'm assuming
people love that
it's been pretty popular it's a beta
feature we're still working out some of
the little ui things it's really
non-trivial because no one's really done
this before
so it's you know there's a lot of user
research that we've had to do
to learn kind of how to uh how to
describe what this is
to to new users one of the biggest fears
we have is you know
someone connects their ledger and thinks
that we have their bitcoin now and they
can just throw their ledger away
right uh because a lot of people don't
really know the ins and outs of how this
stuff works so
getting that stuff those little things
right is is what we're working on uh
before we before we take this out of
beta and we also have a mobile app
coming out soon
so if you connect your if you connect
your ledger to your river account then
on the go like you just open your phone
you can see your whole bitcoin stack uh
on your river app
even if even if you're custodying it
got it and in terms of um seeing a lot
of
uh kind of customers come in use these
different products what are the
features or products that they want that
you guys haven't yet built but kind of
are
think are interesting or on the road map
the app is a big one
so we've been working all summer on
getting a mobile app out
and that's one of the biggest pieces of
feedback we've gotten
we actually do regular we we started
tracking um nps
uh recently so net promoter score to get
feedback from our clients about
would they recommend us to a friend and
if not why and so we collect all these
responses about you know what
customers want from us um we have a
really high nps score actually
uh it's 74 which is pretty high up there
uh for example charles schwab is in the
50s
so you know we're doing pretty well but
but in terms of what people have said
that you know is still missing another
big one is um
when you buy bitcoin from us you can buy
it in one of two ways you can wire us
the funds
and buy that bitcoin that's what people
do for larger orders like 25 000 50 000
plus
and those bitcoin are available to
withdraw immediately
but most people they buy via ach so they
connect their bank account and just
click buy
and then we actually front the money to
buy those bitcoin for people
and um you can buy 24 7 but it takes
six to twenty business days for that
bitcoin to settle in your account
meaning you can't withdraw that bitcoin
for some time period so we're really
focused on
on close on shrinking that settlement
time because a lot of people want to be
able to access their bitcoin faster
and get it off the platform faster so
that's one of the other big pieces of
feedback that we've been trying to
address
um and that and a lot of that is just in
all the back end systems that we have to
build
and then um another big one has been uh
uh
like earning earning like yields
on bitcoin has been something people
have asked for um
iras is another popular one being able
to buy bitcoin into an ira
uh you know a lot of people you can
actually if you have an ira llc
you can already buy bitcoin and river
through your ira llc but um
it you know that's something that's
definitely very interesting to people
who want to buy bitcoin in a tax
advantaged way
yeah talk a little bit about uh kind of
building the company itself like the
team
uh you've done this in the heart of a
global pandemic an economic shock
it seems like everything that could
possibly go wrong in the world has gone
wrong in 2020
how has that been just as kind of the
founder of a company and building up
that team
and have you guys made any changes that
are material in terms of how you thought
about that
so when we raised our latest financing
we raised it in the depths of the
pandemic like the worst days
of the pandemic i was on the phone with
investors
we pulled it off we were one of the very
lucky few companies
that was actually able to pull off a
fundraising man
and one of the saving graces for us was
that
if anything was gonna be like the black
swan that came out of this
mess uh the phoenix coming out of the
you know the ashes
it would be bitcoin and i think that's
where we're seeing that
happening that said you know it hasn't
been all smooth i mean
covet brings has brought its own set of
challenges um
you know increasing building a product
organization that is effective
in a remote environment is tough you
know there's so much that you get just
from being in the same room
and eating a meal with somebody ideas
just spark
and being able to replicate that online
is very very challenging
and so there that's been a big focus of
ours is just figuring out how to
you know build good remote teams uh
and then on top of that i think
um in many ways this covet thing has
kind of been good for business
uh you know it's driven a lot of
trends that are in bitcoin and are there
that are tailwinds for bitcoin
but um you know so so i don't know uh i
don't know what's gonna happen
at the end of the day here with the
fallout of all of this i think it's
still very early and
you know the next decade we'll we'll see
what
what the end result is yeah it's
fascinating to me how teams are having
to kind of figure this out in real time
uh thankfully a lot of the products
though are in place or platforms are in
place to allow
uh some of this kind of remote
communication i had a friend who
basically said imagine if all of this
happened
and we didn't have uh the internet or
you know some of this technology like
what would people do right
yeah yeah no exactly
um and you know we're seeing some other
some other
like it's also accelerating the move
away from cash
which is you know it's kind of scary
right because cash is one of these
ways you can use money anonymously and
securely and now
it's drive this is driving a trend
towards everyone you know
kind of having money uh everyone's
transactions are now
kind of accessible to the surveillance
apparatus and so privacy is
is a big we're losing a lot of privacy
you know as a country
and so you know how does bitcoin come in
and replace that gap i don't know like
we still have to see
um what else can help you know bring
back some of the privacy
as things are just really forced online
during this era of covid so these are
things we're trying to pay attention to
as well
and see what opportunities there are
there because
you know there are very interesting
problems new problems
in society that we didn't have a year
ago that um
i think people are starting to wrap
their heads around
for sure talk a little bit about the
economic situation you mentioned that
there's a lot of people buying bitcoin
maybe out of fear
or concern uh how do you guys see this
unfolding and it sounds like you're
pretty bullish in terms of bitcoin's
outlook
kind of coming out of all this
absolutely i think
this has been brought a lot of people's
attention to bitcoin
uh the biggest thing the best thing
bitcoin has going for it is that there's
only ever gonna be 21 million
everyone understands that everyone
understands there's only ever going to
be
20 million bitcoin uh the federal
government just printed two trillion
dollars this year
so you have all these people sitting on
a lot of cash thinking
well what the heck am i doing with all
this cash when they're just printing it
out of thin air
where do i put it um and i think that's
like i think just like
that meme that narrative is the game
changer you know
21 million it is and so
um i i think that's going to be the best
thing bitcoin has going for it over the
next few years as
every country in the world just prints
unlimited amounts of money
and uh gold's kind of is the
gold is the historical you know
hedge that people use but um
in the computer era you know as
everything comes online
i think people are are increasingly
going to start looking at bitcoin over
gold
yeah i think it's uh i think it's headed
in that direction that's for sure
one of the things i don't know if you
even remember this story but i want to
tell it on here when
when we set this up is uh i went out
to uh to see you and uh when i was in
san francisco came to the office
uh you a bunch of your co-founders and
employees um
and we were sitting there and somebody
basically said hey come into the office
right so we're sitting the conference
room
and i walked in and i'll never forget
that your office was littered and
when i talked about littered i mean
literally all over the place
with uh venezuelan boliviars
with uh what is it zimbabwe dollars i
mean just
all kinds of these currencies that have
failed that i think is bought off ebay
maybe talk a little bit about like
where did you get this stuff from why
was there so much of it laying around
the office
and kind of what you guys do with it
yeah so we have a lot of stacks
um of kind of look like if floyd may if
floyd mayweather lived in zimbabwe
uh it's kind of what our office looks
like sometimes uh we get stacks of like
trillion dollar bills
10 billion dollar bills uh all over the
office
we we have different suppliers for these
um but we we give these to customers
and people who visit the office it's
it's kind of our thing
and um it is we we send it to to
many new clients uh with with a welcome
package
and as a reminder of you know what can
happen to government money
and what kind of inevitably happens with
government money
and uh we you know we have a lot of
things in our office to also just like
build the culture of the team and we
remind everybody why we're doing this
right our goal is to bring sound money
access to sound money to people all over
the world
and um you know for another example of
this is we have a
a poster of executive order 6102 in our
office
which is the order that franklin
roosevelt um the executive order
franklin roosevelt issued to confiscate
people's gold
in the united states um my my co-founder
andrew who's also my cousin our great
grandfather had his gold confiscated by
franklin roosevelt
so you know these things are these
things happen
and they inevitably happen whenever
there's a centrally controlled
money that you can just arbitrarily
print more of
um and uh and so yeah i mean
it's just core to who we are and we like
to remind our clients of that
i love that uh before i go to wrap up
where can people find you
on the internet or find more about uh
river
so we're river.com it's really easy to
find uh
you know check out check out the website
um i'm really easy to reach
uh at alex river.com or check out my
twitter i'm at leashman
l-e-i-s-h-m-a-n and uh yeah so if you
ever
have any questions about bitcoin or just
want to talk shop want to learn more
about river
feel free to reach out always happy to
talk how'd you get the river.com url
oh that's a good question uh so
we went through a period last year
where we had to rebrand and
we we went through a three-month process
of trying to figure out a new name and
we worked with a domain broker
to go through just probably hundreds
maybe even thousands of
uh domains that were available that had
a name that we would
want and i saw a river in one of the
lists
after probably two months and i was like
there's no way we could afford this but
like
let's see um let's see what and so
uh you know the guys selling it had
owned it since the
early 90s and um
the price was actually kind of like
reasonable and it for us it was a
no-brainer you know we pulled the
trigger and haven't looked back
and couldn't be happier with our name
will you say how much uh
no okay fair favorite
less than voice.com for those that don't
know voice.com uh was bought but for 30
billion dollars from michael saylor
who's the ceo of microstrategy and
recently put
85 percent of his balance sheet in the
bitcoin uh which is pretty
crazy story in itself um all right so
i'm glad you spent less than 30 million
dollars that that's a
uh 0 to 30 million is not a big range at
all
yeah yeah exactly um all right uh same
two questions for everybody then you get
asked me one to uh to finish up
first one is uh your favorite book
or most important book you've read of
all time
the richest man in babylon my dad read
it to me when i was a kid
never forgot it that is a fantastic one
i always say there's three books for me
rich dad poor dad versus man in babylon
and think and grow rich so
uh that that's a great one uh aliens
believer or non-believer
believer why
i think that we're not alone in this
universe i think that at some point
we'll discover
why we haven't been contacted
but i think we're just it's such so
early in our civilization that wrapping
our head around the wise is
is too difficult aliens might might
exist in different dimensions
um might exist in a reality that we
don't quite comprehend
uh so that's why i'm super interested in
space exploration but also just like fun
deeply increasing our fundamental
understanding of physics i think we just
have so much further to go in the
fundamental sciences and
um we'll discover things that blow our
minds
hundreds of years from now i think that
you're closer to uh to being accurate
than not
so it's uh it's it's amazing right i
uh somebody sent me an article um who
was it
oh the founder of athletic brewing one
of the uh the sponsors on the podcast
shout out to athletic brewing uh they
the founder sent me a
article about fusion um and the ability
to try to get
the heat and energy of a star recreated
here on earth
i blew my mind like you start reading
about this stuff right and it's like
you know they haven't done it yet but
they're getting closer and closer and
you're just like
wait till somebody figures out how to do
that and then can you create like fusion
power plants so that you have
you know eternal energy sources it's
like just like okay this is gonna be
wild
hopefully i'm alive for that one right
uh you gonna ask me one question to
finish up what one question you got for
me
when will the first central bank buy
bitcoin or have they already
i think they already have yeah i think
that is probably a nefarious
uh actor like a venezuela uh
an iran uh north korea somebody like
that
uh but i think for sure they already
have uh publicly i think venezuela said
they were thinking about it like adding
it as a reserve asset
but i i think we're past the point of
somebody buying it
i think the more nuanced question is
like
when will the first superpower central
bank do it
um and my guess is that we're years away
you know
five years away or something like that
okay what do you think
yeah i mean i think i think i probably
agree there's maybe some friends central
bank that's bought a little bit
um and i think that someone has to
catalyze the first central bank to buy
bitcoin i don't think it's just going to
happen
and so you know i think um i think maybe
one of the questions just for
for people in bitcoin is you know what
what do we all need to build
to like really push this to the next
level and um
you know that's that's kind of how i
think so uh
i've got this theory that the only way a
lot of this is going to happen is for
uh bitcoiners to get into these
positions
right exactly so so like at what point
do we get
i don't know seven or eight of i think
the 12 federal reserve governors or
bitcoiners
i always say bitcoin is an individual
story you know
every institution that's going to have a
massive allocation of bitcoin
is going to have that because
individuals at that institution have
gone down the rabbit hole
and so you know i always think it's
going to be a story about the
individuals and the individuals who end
up running the institutions of the world
so takes time i think that's a fair way
to look at it
all right alex listen you're doing a
fantastic job please keep building what
you're building we need more bitcoin
only companies
uh and obviously from the uh the market
uh response i think that it's pretty
clear people want this so uh
we're cheering for you and we will have
to do this again in the future
thanks a lot tom it's a pleasure